welcome to the second of this series
Sadler's honest book reviews in which i
look at literature having to do with
philosophy particularly practical
philosophy leadership communication all
sorts of things that pertain to how we
live our lives today I'm very happy to
be reviewing this book Massimo Pig Leo
cheese how to be a stoic using ancient
philosophy to live a modern life now I
do have to give you a bit of a warning
ahead of time Massimo is somebody who I
know quite well and actually work with
so he's a colleague and and friends so
it doesn't mean I'm gonna be taking it
easy on him but I always want to give
people fair warning ahead of time this
is a copy that was sent to me by the
publisher basic books for me to review
some time back and what I'll say about
this right off the bat for those who
want the thumbnail sketch is it's a
great introduction to stoic thought it
focuses particularly on epictetus but
range is over a lot of other material I
think it's a faithful transmission of
stoic ideas written for the common
person so this really makes a major
contribution to the popular literature
on stoicism that we find getting getting
put out today so my recommendation is to
get it there are a few little points
that I'll talk about in the very end
where I find myself not completely in
disagreement but but at least not on
exactly the same page but on the whole
it's a really good book and I would
suggest it for anybody who has an
interest in learning more about stoicism
all right so let's get down to the
nitty-gritty now let's talk about the
style of the work the structure of the
work and then sort of a summary of some
of the key ideas that are being worked
on throughout this this book so it's got
a very interesting style a good portion
of it is is sort of the typical present
things for a modern you know non
philosophical audience and I think
Massimo does that quite well but one of
the striking bits about this is that
much of it is actually framed as sort of
an ongoing dialogue or conversation with
one of the greatest of the stoic
philosophers epictetus you know and and
so Massimo is drawing on passages from
the enchiridion and from Epictetus as
much longer discourses which most of the
enchiridion is drawn from we think that
some of the enchiridion may be drawn
from some of the lost books of the
discourses but we still have a good
portion and what Massimo is doing is
sort of blending those those into his
own text so that Epictetus is providing
responses to kind of the common
questions or concerns that are gonna
come up from a contemporary audience so
I actually think that's a very
successful strategy he brings in a
number of other thinkers as well many of
whom are stoic philosophers and then
some of whom are other ancient
philosophers but not Stoics and a number
of contemporary thinkers well
contemporary going back say through the
last two centuries as well so the book
is actually as far as its its structure
broken down into fourteen chapters
there's of course you know beginning
with kind of an introduction and Massimo
sets this up along a very popular way of
presenting stoic philosophy that is also
taken from
epictetus so I think it does make sense
to use it here and that is to
distinguish these three disciplines the
discipline of desire
discipline of action and then the
discipline of a cent and so there are
four chapters given to each of those
there's two chapters at the beginning
and then what we find is a nice little
summary of Hellenistic schools of
practical philosophy at the very end
there there are plenty of you know notes
where you're gonna find out where these
things are coming from it's it's very
well documented there's a pretty good
index so for the reader who wants those
sorts of features I think that this is
going to be very useful text so let's
talk now about what you're gonna find in
this work massimo starts out in chapter
1 by talking about how he himself ended
up arriving at stoicism and i think this
may be familiar to some readers already
if they've looked at his bloggers if
they know his works but it's it's a
great narrative nonetheless and i think
that that can be quite interesting for
many people he's talking about his own
development so it's like a little tiny
mini memoir of intellectual life and and
also situating that in relation to some
of the other big movements of the the
contemporary age or those that have
survived into it if he mentions for
example how he situation situates
himself in relation to the New Atheism
and then the second chapter is a road
map for the journey where he gives us
sort of an overview of stoic thought in
general how we might view it you know
where the Stoics have been you know
successful where they haven't you might
say and then he launches into these
these three main sections like I said
each of which consists of four chapters
so in the discipline of of desire it's
subtitled what it is proper to want or
not to want this is something that the
Stoics paid a lot of attention to and
and Massimo zeroes in on four main
things in
his chapters he starts out by talking
about Epictetus is famous distinction
between what is in our power what is up
to us and what is not this is something
that a lot of people take as sort of the
one-liner for for what constitutes
stoicism in general and it does come to
us primarily from Epictetus although we
can see discussions of that is well in
other earlier stoic philosophers just
not as fully developed and any you know
he goes through it and addresses a
number of the issues that typically
arise he's got some great examples in
here
chapter four he's looking at this this
conception that the Stoics had that's
also a one-liner stoicism as living in
accordance with nature well that raises
a lot of questions for the contemporary
reader particularly since we often have
very different conceptions of what
counts as nature fuzes in Greek now
Torah in Latin then did the ancient
Stoics and again Massimo I think does a
great job in running through some of
these these contemporary understandings
explaining how the Stoics had something
different in mind where the stoic point
of view might be in need of some
reinterpretation Massimo's
reinterpretation is largely to live in
accordance with nature means to live in
accordance with with reason or to live
rationally and you know here he's really
at his strength I mean this is something
that Massimo has been writing about in
many other works for for quite a long
time and engaging in debates about then
he brings up this issue of the chapter
title is playing ball with Socrates and
he talks about the the notion of
indifference which which is a great you
know conception that the Stoics didn't
completely originate but but certainly
made the most out of and I think it
winds up being kind of a tripping point
for many people who are studying
stoicism in the present now it's
interesting there's a little side note
that even back in the Stoics don't
they're like listen I understand this is
technological or this is technical
language here's what we actually mean by
it because they were continually
misunderstandings arising about that and
and so you know he's got some some great
examples in here and then interestingly
enough bringing out the the you know
sort of theological dimensions he talks
in this chapter Gadar Adams about where
he differs from
epictetus and from the Stoics massimo is
kind of a famous atheist skeptic you
know he made his bones I think in many
respects writing and speaking about this
sort of stuff so it would you know it
would be strange for him to be having a
religious conversion in terms of
stoicism and so he's talking about how
you know modern stoicism might differ
from that of epictetus who is probably
one of the most religiously oriented
Stoics and the other stoic philosophers
how you know what are the prospects for
for a current stoic in terms of
religious belief and so that that's a
very useful discussion I think then once
he starts moving to the discipline of
action thinking about no longer just how
we we desire and are averse to things
but also you know what we do this is
sometimes called the discipline of
choice you know as well as the
discipline of action he focuses in the
first place about character and the
virtues and this is another key stoic
idea that that the goal of life is to
live in accordance with virtue
the Stoics did famously hold that only
virtue is the good and only vice is the
bad in the fullest sense for human
beings
so Massimo does a great job in
developing this there's a really
interesting discussion where he's
bringing in sort of cross-cultural
discussion not only of the four cardinal
virtues but also of several others
humanity and transcendence and he shows
how stoicism properly understood can fit
in with that
that he's got this really interesting
discussion a very crucial word where he
starts out talking about the Medea and
he's going to eventually discuss what's
called a mafia and there's different
ways of translating this and I think
Massimo does a good job it's not merely
ignorance it's kind of a thoughtlessness
it's a not thinking things through
entirely and this addresses the question
about well how is it that people can in
fact do things that they seem to think
are bad if they know they're bad why are
they why are they doing them and so
Massimo's got a very nice discussion of
that in here something that I should
mention he also made a core of his
presentation at the most recent stoic on
chapter 9 looks at role models and how
it is that Stoics themselves provided
and looked to role models and how we
might do that as well here he talks
about Admiral Stockdale and his use of
epictetus in the prison camps in North
Vietnam during the Vietnamese war and
then finally a really important chapter
I think chapter 10 disability and mental
illness the question that's being raised
is you know it is stoicism applicable to
the the range of things that fall into
the category these days of mental
illness or is it really a therapy that
that you know as we might say about
philosophical counseling quite famously
Lou and marinovka winds us a therapy for
the sane and Massimo's answer is as it
should be yes and no not everything that
we call mental illness today is
necessarily amenable to to applying
stoic philosophy but a good bit of it is
and so there's a nice interface between
there and he brings up Lawrence Becker's
if you don't know Lawrence Becker's work
a new stoicism his his discussion of his
own adversities that he faced and how
stoicism helped
with that so I think that's that's
actually a very nice nuanced treatment
then we move on to the discipline of the
scent how we how we react to things
Massimo has a chapter here on death and
and suicide
you know the Stoics were quite famous
for having committed suicide in certain
circumstances I should mention here that
you know it's very clear from the stoic
point of view that suicide is not really
a good option for most people it's only
in very unique circumstance we're not
unique but but certain circumstances
restricted circumstances and when the
person himself or herself is really
doing it because of their character not
just as an escape but death is also an
interesting thing to bring up the Stoics
were famously materialist so how do they
actually view death as not itself being
an evil then there's a great chapter
here chapter 12 how to deal with anger
anxiety and loneliness probably three of
the most important and yet also
devastating effects that we feel in in
modern life they were also pretty
important in ancient life as well and
the Stoics have a lot to say about that
then what might be a bit of a surprise
to many people chapter 13 love and
friendship
Massimo begins with one of my favorite
passages where Epictetus has this guy
who was just abandoned his daughter when
she was sick coming to him saying that
he did so out of familial affection and
I pick Tina says I'm not quite sure
about that let's let's consider this so
there's some great discussion in here
about how we how we feel affection how
we love whether that has a role in
stoicism and the answer of course is yes
it indeed it does and then finally we
finish up with with a chapter that I
guess does belong in the discipline of
ascent the way Massimo is looking at it
the way it's traditionally understood
which are practical spiritual exercises
and you know stoicism is a practical
philosophy it has a whole theoretical
apparatus
as well and I don't want to downplay
that but it is a philosophy oriented
towards living and one of the cool
things about the Stoics is that they did
in fact give us a number of different
really useful exercises some of which
overlap with other spiritual or
intellectual or you know religious
traditions but you know these are
particularly good Massimo picks out 12
of these I'm not going to try to provide
a summary of them here I'll just say
that these are you know pretty much
classic ways of approaching things I
think it's a good number to work with
and so then he finishes with this
appendix on the Hellenistic schools of
practical philosophy doing a little bit
of comparative work and I think he does
a good job overall with this so that's
the style the structure and the summary
of of this how to be a stoic
all right so with a book like this I'm
not going to try to sum up everything
that I found positive about the book
because I think that would be quite long
and might not be very helpful for the
viewer I'll just pick some things that I
myself found particularly good and then
a few things that I think might help you
make a decision about whether you want
to get or read this book as somebody
who's coming to it for for the first
time or perhaps somebody who's read some
about stoicism but is looking for some
engaging secondary literature I will say
this to start with so this is definitely
always say it's not his first rodeo this
is definitely not Massey most first bull
that he's riding on he's a you know
well-established author and then I think
that really shows not just in how
well-constructed
the book is but also in the way in which
he frames things you're almost always
gonna find a relatable example sometimes
taken from his own experience sometimes
from that of others
he's giving you I think for the you know
the general reader the right amount of
background and going to the right amount
of depth at least on on nearly
everything that that he's talking about
here so you know this is this is very
well-written very well-constructed
I think that you know if I if I look at
the the stoic components of this book
Massimo is not going to lead you astray
on anything and I actually you know this
is sort of a great test for me when I
read through something like this
do I somebody who's been studying
stoicism for four decades get something
out of it and does it make me think a
little bit more about things and the
answer is yes so really nice nice work
here one of the other things that I do
want to mention is that I like the fact
that you know he's without sort of you
know just dumbing it down he's bringing
in a lot of all
their discussions that that can you know
lead somebody into reading other things
so for example when he's talking about
stoic conceptions of a mafia or
ignorance or how we get things screwed
up he brings up Hana Arendt and the
banality of evil and he doesn't do the
sort of typical hack job that'll hot
people do with that in part cuz he's
trying to think about well what does
this actually mean for us so you know I
think it's a good discussion of that you
know Massimo is an old hand at you know
the evolution versus creationism stuff
that comes up in here to some extent in
and in an interesting way too he doesn't
just track about listen what does Darwin
mean for living in accordance with
nature he also tells us something really
cool there's a great anecdote in here
where he's talking about getting
involved in these you know debates and
discussions and being impressed by the
fact that there were people on the other
side who were you might say you know
engaging him in good faith and even
though they disagreed with him they
wanted to you know converse with him and
have meals with him and and he realized
that the new atheists were in some
respects kind of shooting themselves in
the foot by being so militant and so
uncompromising and dismissive of
religious people and stoicism you know
would provide a different way of going
about that there's a lot of other people
who he brings in you know it talks about
cognitive psychology and positive
psychology developmental psychology with
Kohlberg and Piaget you know I think
that's kind of interesting in the
section on death he brings up
transhumanism and reycarts vials you
know notions and so there's a lot of
really good engagement of what you could
call the contemporary intellectual
culture being done here I mentioned he
does also talk about the New Atheists
and where he finds himself differing
from them so there's that there's also
some some good discussion and you know
bringing in contemporary stoic figures
like Bill Irvine like Lawrence Becker
like Admiral James Stockdale
he also talks about his colleague loom
Aronoff and the philosophical counseling
movement so there's a lot of threads
that the reader could follow out and I
think Massimo's book gives you enough
meat that you would want to follow them
out without overwhelming you with you
know going off on a tangent as a matter
of fact you could say that one of the
one of the real strengths of this book
is that while it does seem to be going
off on tangents here and there it's
always coming back very quickly to the
the main points so it's a you know a
quick trek through this this book
another thing that I think I really like
about this book is that one of the
things that that Massimo does is sort of
sets up where these contemporary
dichotomies of thought typically lie
mentioned the you know religion versus
New Atheism he also talks about you know
modern liberals and conservatives and
you know a number of other different
dichotomous ways of dividing up the
world and he shows how stoicism and I
think you can say this is not just about
stoicism but other other forms of virtue
ethics is not going to fall on either of
these sides but kind of go in a
different trajectory which gives us a
better understanding so in a lot of
these you know hey is that this or this
either/or the stoic is gonna say well a
bit of both and then this that's even
better than those and I think Massimo is
doing a good job with that I really love
the idea of putting yourself in
conversation with epictetus I think that
that's an important aspect of studying
any any figure that we do want to place
ourselves in kind of intellectual
dialogue I think this book demonstrates
to us one way I don't want to say the
only way but one way that that can be
done quite well so I think that's a
great model for the contemporary reader
and the last thing that I'll say about
it is that I think he's really good at
contextualizing stoic ideas not just
within
you know though our larger society or
the fabric of our lives but also in
relation to the you know the development
of stoicism as a doctrine so you know
these are all a lot of the what for me
are sort of high points about this work
no work is ever perfect or without any
flaw whatsoever it would be kind of
strange to expect that and there are a
few places where I found myself you know
not entirely happy with where the book
was going I understand that it's written
for a popular audience so these might
seem something like a scholars quibbles
and and I will say that I do think that
they're they're pretty minor but I would
like to signal them I'll start by
talking about the the very end of the
book where we have the Hellenistic
schools of practical philosophy and and
I you know I think that it's it's not
technically correct to say that the
Epicureans are somehow tracing
themselves back to Socrates through the
sea Rene X I understand why Massimo who
I think does you know know this quite
well would would allow that to sort of
slip into the book because it makes
things a little bit simpler and second
it you know kill a reader right to find
that out but I mean the epicurean school
was really a non Socratic school there's
a little bit of controversy about this
even in the ancient period but but most
of the scholarship is on the side of
definitely Epicurus and his followers
are like you know doing something
different they're coming from a
different line and so I you know that's
one issue the other thing that I'll say
about that chapter is one one thing
that's totally missing and talking about
the Hellenistic schools as being ways of
life there's there no discussion of
skepticism whether that a pie in a pyro
nyan skepticism which definitely was a
way of life or the skepticism of the
Academy with some of its key figures who
were writing at the same time as the
early Stoics and and you know responding
to them so this I think is a little bit
of a gap in here and you know one could
quibble about the presentation of a few
other things but you know that's that
chapter there there are
you other little things here and there
Massimo says that Aristotle in talking
about the virtues was obsessed with
taxonomy z' and he gives us an example
of that the fact that he proposed it
proposed a whopping 12 different types
of virtue rather than the Stoics simple
for even though all types of virtue of
really just different aspects of wisdom
I understand that that that's sort of a
good talking point it's not technically
correct I mean if you think that
Aristotle was obsessed with taxonomy
'he's just read some stoic literature
and you'll find that the Stoics
themselves engaged in all sorts of
taxonomic discussions about things so I
don't think that's a peculiarly
Aristotelian thing as a matter of fact
the plainest did that as well I would
say that's sort of endemic and then you
know twelve types of virtue I mean if
we're talking about the the moral
virtues it's actually eleven you know
there's a question of whether practical
wisdom belongs in there how it fits in
there and you know there's a bit more
structure to it I think in Aristotle's
presentation than is being presented
here and the Stoics themselves when they
had those four kinds of virtue they also
broke them down into a whole bunch of
sub virtues as well so let's not pretend
that you know there were just the four
cardinal virtues and that made it super
simple so I think that's that's kind of
kind of important I would say that you
know in the this book really is not
designed to do this but I would say that
it's a little bit weird to me to see you
know discussing the the virtues and the
cardinal virtues and and you know how
they connect with you know stoicism and
and Christianity to see all of the
Christian thinkers up to Thomas Aquinas
totally jumped over you know so he says
what are the Christians do with the
Socratic package of virtues they took it
on board wholesale and expanded it
Thomas Aquinas one of the most
influential Christian theologians of all
time developed the notion of heavenly
virtues I don't think so I mean already
there are plenty of other thinkers
talking about
faith hope and charity there there are a
number of others that they would discuss
as well like humility and obedience so
this is a bit of oversimplification but
again I I understand what where he's
going with that the only other quibble I
have that I'm not quite sure about is
where in discussing the argument from
design massimo says that that it's you
know the first cogent attack on the
argument from design came from david
hume i'm not really sold about that you
know cicero has this great dialogue on
the nature of the gods which I actually
think that Humes work is indebted to and
he has a skeptic in there arguing
against the epicurean and stoic
positions the Stoics actually did rely
on something like a design argument and
I think we can find other interesting
attacks may be what Massimo means is the
first really devastating attack against
the design argument comes from David
David Hume if you say that I think that
could make sense these are all fairly
minor quibbles with it on the whole it's
really a good book
alright simply put to bring this to a
close I think that if you don't already
have this book you probably do want to
get it and read it even if you know
quite a bit about stoicism it's a great
read you're gonna you know rethink some
things along the way I really like the
way that that Massimo set this up and
how you know epictetus is done I'm a big
fan of epic these so if you make epic
Tina's your central figure you're
probably gonna get my eye but I think
that's a really important thing to do so
I highly recommend this book you know
it's it's available now in a number of
translations a number of different
versions easy enough to get your hands
on I think this is going to be looking
ahead to the future understood as being
you know one of the one of the central
pieces of popular stoic literature that
does a really good job in staying true
to the original text but also in
explaining things well for a
contemporary audience of non-specialists
non-academics
you